Alright, so I'm going to do an execution. I got requested to show how I use this model.
There, we had a market structure shift to the upside. I'm looking for a gap fill from
Friday's close. So I'm going to go long here, 12 micros of a mini NASDAQ, or I'm sorry,
NASDAQ futures contract. So I'm going to look for a price to drop down into that fair value gap,
and look for a run above 14,160. Right now I have my initial interest at 14,180. I'm thinking
14,220 is possible today. Alright, there's my limit entry. Okay, and I'll show you where we're at.
So there's the closure of the fair value gap. Now I'm watching price. I want to see it start
expanding on the upside. I'm not watching the number underneath that profit. Okay, that's not
what I'm watching. I'm watching the candles. Is it constantly going towards that small little
fair value gap around 14,122 to 14,138 or so? I want to see it go through that. Now I can start
to consolidate in that area and reaccumulate for new longs, kind of like a pausing, maybe like,
think like a bull flag. That's kind of like what I anticipate forming between 14,120, 14,140 in that
area. Similar to what we just watched right there. So if I want to expansion the upside solid, it
looks good. I'm thinking I might take the limit order up to 14,220, but we'll see how we trade
above the short-term high made prior to 10 o'clock in the morning. Nice little run above new equity
high. Nice placement on the entry. That's probably random. Alright, buy side sitting right around that
14,160 level that's in the crosshairs right now. Typically you'll see it usually consolidate around
here. Maybe small little retracement gets everybody thinking it's time to sell short. Remember
resistance ideas from retail. They're gonna see that 160 and say, okay, I'm gonna get short because
it went down from there the last time. So I'm not thinking that. I'm thinking it's gonna like
swap bust through the door and run up into that 14,180. I might adjust that in here. Okay, so that's
kind of like my best case scenario and this is what I'm gonna try to take six contracts off above
here. So I'm thinking if it runs there, I'll take six off to fund the position, roll the stops to
even, and then see if I can get that limit order at 14,220. Small little consolidation around that
fair of a gap level as I mentioned before. Reaching into an order block now. I'm looking at e-mini S&P
micro just to get a feel. Looks like it wants to run as high as well. So it kind of like gives me
fuel or confidence that this is gonna run up into that level. So I'm gonna take my six contracts
off and I'm gonna change my mind and close it here because it's getting real close to the closure
of that gap. I might be wrong, but just for general principles, 14,220 I think is doable.
Alright, there's the business. Limit order filled. Again, I'll hover over top the entry so you can
see it. Alright, there is your entry and that's not bad. It's the low candle. That's what I like to
show you guys. There's the limit order exiting there. So, hopefully you found this insightful.
James, there's your example. Until next time, be safe.